hello everyone welcome to the mindscape
podcast I'm your host Sean Carroll
welcome to the first podcast of 2023 and
to start out I want to do a little
thought experiment here imagine that I
told you that if you go to patreon.com
Sean M Carroll you could pledge a small
amount of money to support mindscape and
in return you would get the ability to
listen to ad-free versions of the
podcast as well as to ask questions at
the monthly AMA ask me anything episodes
now that's true I've said that to you
before you probably already know it but
I'm not actually pitching the patreon
right now instead I want to think about
what is going on in your mind when I say
those words we're Conjuring up an image
right you can imagine doing that going
to patreon kicking in a dollar per
episode or what have you or you could
imagine not doing it you can contemplate
different hypothetical futures this is
an ability that human beings have to
think counterfactually to not just say
this is happening therefore that in
other words not to just be automatic or
unconscious about our reactions to what
is going on but to think through
different hypothetical possibilities
even hypothetical possibilities that
involve things in the future not just
right now right here right this moment
but at some undetermined time in the
future there's different hypothetical
possibilities and we can sit down
imagine them and choose which one we
want this is a remarkable ability and
it's not at all an obvious one to evolve
over biological time in fact arguably it
is only human beings who have this
ability of all the different animal
species or plant species for that matter
here on Earth the ability to what we
call mentally time travel to put
ourselves in hypothetical future
situations as well as of course to
remember real past situations or even to
remember fake past situations for that
matter this ability to imagine ourselves
at different moments of time in
different situations seems to be
uniquely human now of course it's a
spectrum right I mean it's not a hard
and fast thing there are plenty of
animals that have plenty of impressive
abilities to do other things but we
certainly do it way more in much more
detail and it's kind of implicitly
crucial to who we are as a social
species right it allows us the reason
why I chose the patreon example not just
to pitch the patreon but also because
it's not just imagination in the sense
of you know artistic imagination or even
scientific imagination it enables us to
make agreements with other human beings
it opens a new social Dimension to our
lives we can make contracts explicit
contracts or implicit ones we can agree
if you do this then at some other future
moment I'm going to do that that ability
is absolutely crucial to make us human
beings certainly to make this kind of
society and Cooperative culture that we
can that we do have and we do enjoy so
today's guest Adam bully is a
psychologist who recently collaborated
with two other psychologists Thomas
sudendorff and Jonathan redshaw on a
book called The Invention of Tomorrow a
natural history of foresight where they
talk about exactly this all three of
them have done research and exactly this
area how the ability to mentally time
travel evolved over Evolution and what
role it's played in human history how
important it is there's certainly a
strong relationship between this and
another episode we had with Malcolm
McIver some time back where we talked
about a much earlier moment in
evolutionary history where the first
fish climbed on to land and that might
have been the very beginning of this
ability to mentally time travel but
human beings have developed it much
later in evolutionary history to an
extraordinary degree and that it really
is very very crucial that's the point
that they're trying to make in this book
that it's not just going along for the
ride this ability to put ourselves in
the future has made us human in a very
very real way so this is something you
know combining Humanity with time travel
things like that this is exactly the
kind of thing I'd love to talk about on
the podcast a good way to start the year
2023 so let's go
[Music]
Adam bully welcome to mindscape podcast
fantastic to be here thanks for uh
thanks for having me so I wanted to
start with a provocative factoid that
you mentioned in your book or you've
shared around which is that chimpanzees
will say hello to each other they'll
greet each other when they meet but they
do not say goodbye is that accurate yes
that is accurate they they tend to greet
each other very uh affectionately
they'll sometimes even like you know
give each other a little high five like
you know hug and a kiss but uh Jane
Goodall frequently remarks that they do
not uh bid each other farewell and one
of the the sort of reasons for that is
that they do not really have the same
kind of capacity for foresight they
can't imagine themselves meeting again
in the future and so there's not really
any real point in bidding one another
goodbye if of course there is no
anticipated reunion in the future I mean
I guess we'll get into this in great
detail but how do you know that is this
built up in a whole bunch of different
ways or is there some direct way in
which we can say the chimpanzees cannot
anticipate meeting each other
well it's a it's obviously a very uh
deep question it's a complex question
about exactly how you ascertain the
abilities of other animals in any
cognitive domain you obviously use
various tools there's comparative
psychology there's ecology looking at
the behavior in in their natural
environments I built up a you know
there's a lot of observational work done
but at the end of the day one of the key
things required is just is is systematic
scientific studies of animal
competencies obviously you can't read
their minds and they can't talk to us to
tell us what they're thinking about you
know no chimpanzee is going to say oh no
I'm not saying goodbye because I'm not
going to see him again and so what you
need to do is systematically controlled
scientific studies and and many of those
have been done over the over the past
few decades because the question of
whether other animals can think ahead in
time is obviously very important when if
you're trying to make some kind of claim
like we do in in our book that thinking
ahead is one of the key things that
makes us human good so let's I'll give
you the opportunity to Define exactly
what it is we're talking about because I
know there's all these subtleties
between like planning and anticipating
and thinking ahead uh uh mental time
travel so what are we focusing on here
okay so yes very good point it's a
complex multifaceted topic we're talking
specifically at least you know in this
in this sense about the ability to
specifically imagine think about the
distant future and to organize your
behavior accordingly that's the kind of
foresight that we have in mind here
obviously there's other kinds of future
oriented behavior and we go through some
of them in the book that include things
like planning as you just mentioned so
the ability for instance for an animal
to face a a maze and navigate through
that maze requires some kind of planning
capacity because there's a requirement
to find the way through the maze to a
goal to a Target and other animals have
goals they pursue things they they
navigate through space and obviously
through time as they're doing it and
what you find in humans though is a is a
capacity to imagine ourselves in a
remote future time for vividly
pre-experiencing what might happen to us
and you also see this ability to
anticipate mutually exclusive possible
future events
simultaneously as opposed to for example
cycling between them as a rat might do
while going through a maze and we can
you know we can dive into any of these
different aspects of of future oriented
cognition and you know at the end of the
day we don't really think of foresight
as just one thing it's not like a module
in the brain instead it's a suite of
interacting capacities that kind of work
together to enable complex future
directed actions well I like the
the the word you use pre-experiencing I
hadn't heard that one before so I is
that sort of at the heart of the
distinction we're drawing here like
famously squirrels will gather nuts uh
to tide them over the winter okay but
that that could arguably be said to just
be like an automatic thing and they'll
gather things and it will work but
they're not sitting there Imagining the
future winter and visualizing it in any
sense is that okay yeah that's a
fantastic example I mean so as you say
the squirrels that will you know hoard
not in anticipation of future uh winter
food sorted is they will do that even if
they've never experienced a winter
before
and they obviously have no way to tell
each other that there's a forthcoming
Frost and so we know just simply from
that that their behavior is actually
driven by instincts it's a response to
particular kinds of cues in the
environment that will trigger that
behavior
um they are not anticip they're not
actually imagining themselves in a
possible distant future situation where
they don't have the food they need to
sustain themselves and what argument for
that is just that it squirrels that are
less than one year old do this
they'll do it even if you've never if
they've never experienced any winter and
you can you know people have done
experiments on this kind of uh on this
behavior and you can manipulate it
fairly fairly easily in the same way
that if you imagine various other kind
of fixed action patterns that animals
will will do
um some you know famously Nick timberg
and you know if you do know the work
with for example the gray lag Goose that
if the goose has a fixed action pattern
where it will try and roll an egg back
towards its nest if the egg falls out
and that seems very future directed it
seems very intentional because you might
imagine oh no you know the the the goose
is thinking that the baby is potentially
going to be damaged or it's a very
dangerous situation
but if you simply replace the egg with
something else or even remove the egg
entirely once the behavior pattern is
actually initiated the goose will enact
the entire sequence through to
completion regardless of whether the
actual object in question which is the
egg is present or not right okay and so
that's just an example of a kind of
fixed action pattern or an instinctual
behavior that you can see in in animals
that it's revealed to be fairly blind to
the Future simply by the fact that it
can be manipulated by changing the cues
that initiate the behavior good if that
makes sense in contrast to that we're
we're talking about the human capacity
to imagine that we are doing something
different or will be doing something
different so I guess one question is you
know how
what is the relationship between our
imagination in the sense of just
visualizing something different in our
heads and literally indexing that with
oh this is the future that was the past
something like that
okay yeah that's another really good
question because it's it's actually and
it's actually one of the kind of key
question key topics in the scientific
study of memory and Imagination and the
real question kind of just to almost
reformulate what you said and you tell
me if this is on the right lines how
does the brain tag and imagined episode
as being fictional or a memory or
imagined future or any other kind of
context
that comes down in some sense to our
ability to meta represent or to have
some reflective capacity to represent
our own lower uh lower order mental
capacities so for example in theory of
mind uh the the key the key test there
is often the ability to represent that
another person has a false belief oh
yeah and in much the same way I might
need to represent that I could be wrong
about the future I need to represent
that this is just a memory or that this
is fictional for example if I imagine
the same event for example myself eating
a slice of pie I can also reflect on the
fact that that imagined episode in my
mind's eye
it either was a memory that happened to
me I'm remembering the last time I ate a
slice of pie or it's completely
fictional because I I don't eat pie or
it's in the future because I'm imagining
eating pie for dessert tomorrow
um and so that metacognitive capacity is
actually a very essential part of the
puzzle and I guess so like you you
reformulated a more interesting question
that I asked but let me ask the question
that I actually had in mind which is so
it seems like there are two parts one is
like putting on the play in our heads
right like literally
constructing the scenario and another
part is
thinking of it or associating it with
past present future fantasy whatever
like do these necessarily go hand in
hand are they separate parts of the
brain doing different things
yeah good they they are probably uh like
I said earlier foresight is we don't
tend to think of it as just one
encapsulated module and in fact it is
possible to lose various aspects of the
ability to think about the future while
keeping the other parts intact uh and so
maybe it'll be helpful if I kind of
break down some of what we know about
how you put this mental mental play on
as you sort of referred to it
um and uh and we can go from there so
one of the key distinctions first of all
is between what what scientists would
call semantic memory and episodic memory
and so semantic memory for those who who
don't know is our memory for pieces of
information bits of knowledge facts so
for example that the capital of France
is Paris on the other hand you have
episodic memory which is our memory for
the episodes of our life and these are
the kinds of episodes of for example
remembering my my 10th birthday party
and I can vividly recollect that
experience and I can walk through it in
my mind's eye I can remember all of the
details now those two things can
actually be dissociated so they are
they're intertwined but you can lose
access to one while keeping the other
intact okay and so for example in
particular kinds of Amnesia there's a
famous case of uh amnesic patients who
have particular damage to the
hippocampus and that can impair the
ability to actually vividly imagine
future events and remember specific past
episodes while leaving semantic
information intact so for example having
the knowledge that climate change might
affect low-lying coastal regions in the
future without being able to imagine
oneself actually being subject to that
kind of damage
and so that that's just a that's a first
level distinction
um but there's many other aspects to
this mental time machine that we can but
something just happened there that maybe
yeah uh you did say you know and I
missed it but we're talking about
episodic memory but then you related it
to the ability to sort of imagine that
we will be subject to climate change so
is that the same part of the brain that
is putting on the play and uh we use
both in memory and in foresight
one of the most interesting discoveries
of the last 10 years in this area has
been that it is it is indeed the case
that the brain uses much of the same
neural circuitry to remember past
episodes and to imagine future events
that might happen and uh there's been a
lot of neuroimaging work on this
particular question which has found that
if you ask people in an fmri scanner for
example to imagine something happening
to them in the future and you ask them
to remember uh things happening in the
past you see a very very similar
analogous set of neural structures
activated uh in both of those conditions
and that work has been has been led by
Donna rosatis and Daniel schachter uh
collaborators and and they've done many
interesting variations on those kinds of
studies and the picture is emerging that
yes there is a kind of mental time
machine which uses the same same
cognitive resources to go both backwards
and forwards in time and how closely
connected is it to visualization could
we have this kind kind of imagination
without painting a picture in our heads
uh yeah that's a very interesting
question there's been studies done where
you ask people how they're Imagining the
future because people differ in this you
know you might say someone might just
verbally think about what might happen
to them in the future uh well someone
else might vividly imagine it as it
turns out the vast majority of people
when they are asked to imagine something
happening to them in the future and you
know and you modify the wording and
stuff they're doing it visually not it's
not a necessary prerequisite and so in
fact you wouldn't necessarily equate uh
episodic which can be defined more
specifically with regards to the what
where and when details of of an episode
on the one hand and on the other hand
the the visualization capacity to
actually bring an image into the Mind's
Eye for example if I ask you to picture
an apple you can do that you can put
bring it up into your mind's eye and
sort of rotate it you can imagine how it
smells and uh and in that case the brain
is sort of reactivating sensory cortices
in order to bring about that mental
image except some people can't right
some people lack that ability but
presumably they can still remember and
imagine the future
Yes except uh there's been some
interesting studies done recently
looking at a Fantasia which is the this
uh this this inability to generate
mental images in the Mind's Eye
uh showing that these people have a
harder time Imagining the future and
planning for events that might happen
and when we're talking about this kind
of foresight that you're studying
um I guess where does the idea that it
is hypothetical or counter factual or uh
there's more than one possible thing
come in like could we imagine the
ability to imagine ourselves in the
future but still think that it was a
definite thing uh or or did it come hand
in hand with this idea of different
possible worlds as the philosophers
would put it right possible worlds yes
so my my collaborators and co-authors on
on the book uh John redshaw and Thomas
sudendorff have done some really elegant
studies on uh the um development of the
the early cognitive development of the
ability to represent the future as a
branching world of possibilities rather
than just a single definite single track
vision and I'll maybe I'll just describe
one of the the studies which can
elucidate this a little bit so if you
imagine dropping a a grape through a
tube and the tube is just a straight
pipe and at the bottom there's an exit
and you ask a child to catch the grape
what they'll do is they'll put a hand
out and they'll catch it as it comes out
the other side
but now imagine we make the the future a
little harder to predict and you you
turn the single tube into a a forked
tube kind of like an upside down shaped
Y and so now there's a single entrance
point at the top but there's two exits
at the bottom it splits into a fork when
you give that task and you drop a grape
through the top or a prize of some kind
or a ball and you ask a child to catch
it when they're two and three years old
what they tend to do is only put a
single hand out and they'll move the
hand back and forth between the two
exits as if they're guessing where it's
going to come out they're making a
prediction they can they can anticipate
that the ball is going to drop out of
one or the other exit except once they
get to about age four from the first
trial of a task like that children will
actually put both hands out and cover
both of the exits from the tube and what
that seems to imply is that the child
not only makes a prediction about the
future but also represents that they
could be wrong about that prediction and
that therefore they need to make a
contingency plan you know I don't think
they're going through it in all that
much detail you know that's the
experimenter in interpreting it but what
it seems to represent is that they have
the basic cognitive capacity to
represent the future as uh having
mutually exclusive possibilities rather
than just a single track outcome
and so that that ability kind of comes
online very early and what we argue in
the book is that it's actually one of
the most fundamental abilities that that
kind of comprises force I like I said
it's not one thing it's but this ability
to represent the future as possible as a
world of possibilities is really
fundamental to what makes foresight so
powerful and effective if you only had
the ability to represent it as a single
outcome it wouldn't be anywhere near as
useful and one important note about the
relationship to memory is that our
memories are terrible right human beings
are not very good at remembering things
uh is that
does that mean that we're not very good
at Imagining the future or is that
actually a feature that we make use of
in Imagining the future
yeah the eras of memory are probably oh
in one way of thinking about them is
that they're actually a kind of uh
they're either a byproduct or they're a
design feature of the more fundamental
and Powerful ability to imagine the
future I'm going to unpack that slightly
please if you have a a memory system
that is flexible which you can where
where the various bits and pieces from
memories so for example you know that
the man had a hat on and that he you
know that the guy had a mustache and
that there was a coffee cup present and
so on all those bits and pieces from an
episode can be combined and recombined
in flexible ways to enable us to to
remember a vast multitude of previous
events that have happened to us by using
constituent elements so that's a
effective way for the brain to
reconstruct what has happened to it
before without having to store you know
all the specific details from every
single event that has happened
now what that's really useful for though
is when you want to imagine the future
which of course by definition hasn't
happened yet and what the brain does
seem to do is combine and recombine the
elements that we've accrued in memory in
order to imagine possible future events
as well
so for example now I can combine and
recombine that okay there was a mustache
and that there's a coffee cup but now I
can invent a new fictitious scenario
using those basic elements and then
anticipate how certain changes to those
elements might change what eventually
happens in the end so one way I've heard
it described and I'm not I wasn't never
sure whether this was an exaggeration or
not so I'm glad that I have an expert
here to ask but
the memories that we have are really not
like a recording not like a videotape
recording it's more like what we store
is a screenplay and which of course
requires far fewer gigabytes than a
whole video file right and then our
brain has the production capacity to
take in the screenplay and put on a
little play for us and uh and that's the
same kind of
parts of the brain that might be used to
imagine something that hasn't happened
is that a even close to Accurate picture
yeah that's very accurate that's great I
mean and another way it's just more
metaphors but another way of thinking
about it is like that the brain stores a
kind of recipe for the event and then it
uses that recipe to reconstruct the
neural activity that was that did occur
when the event was originally perceived
and encoded and so that's a very
effective way it's kind of like an index
which is uh used to retrieve the various
details and combine them in the
particular configuration or the
particular pattern that they were in
when they were first encoded and so
understanding memory as a kind of patent
reconstruction system
you know computational terms actually
makes sense of a lot of of kind of how
it works and then how it can be used to
imagine the future
uh although I will make a side note
there that the the search for the memory
Trace you know the actual where the
index is stored in the brain has uh has
been a very very difficult search and
it's still ongoing I don't think it's
necessarily settled by any stretch of
the imagination exactly how the brain
stores these traces and then uses that
Trace to reconstruct the whole there's a
lot a lot is understood but it's still
not you know the details are not worked
out well this sounds interesting and
important I want to hear more about this
so what do you mean by the trace uh that
we don't know where it's stored is that
like the the data about what happened at
that particular event that we're trying
to remember
yeah if you think about it in
theoretically speaking what's probably
going on is that the brain is using it
you know when you're perceiving
something when you're encoding some some
event
there's a there's a whole bunch of
details and you need to not only encode
what they were but the relationship
between all the details there's a
certain pattern there about how these
details are combined and what the brain
is probably doing is storing a a trace
or an instructional kind of I don't want
to say a guide but for metaphorical
sense that enables that pattern to be
reconstructed later at will you know
when it when you volitionally attempt to
remember what happened to you in the
past
um and uh you know this might be a good
juncture actually to talk you know a
little bit about the kind of brain
mechanisms of of uh memory and
Imagination and obviously I think we
mentioned briefly the hippocampus
earlier but the the hippocampus is is
really very heavily implicated in all of
this okay so you know if these if these
traces are are to be found uh that's a
good place to look for them uh and uh
the hippocampus is a brain structure in
the medial temporal lobes it's also the
structure that if it's destroyed by some
kind of injury uh or insult to the brain
that's the part that will be removed
that will leave you unable to imagine
yourself in the future in specific uh
circumstances and remember and the
inability to remember specific past
events as well and this is there have
been patients to whom this has happened
so we have the data
we have the data there's a very famous
patient uh who goes by KC in the
literature uh who um this patient you
know had damage to the hippocampus and
the medial temporal lobes and then
despite retaining semantic knowledge and
particular you know knowledge about
particular facts uh he could no longer
remember any event from his personal
life and he could not imagine what would
happen to him in the future so he you
know he's in no position to plan a party
or uh you know imagine what he might do
in the future
um so we have yeah it's a very
interesting patient because if you start
to investigate precisely what he lost
the picture becomes quite complicated so
I'll just give you one little tidbit
it's a this patient KC he would still
discount rewards in the future according
to the same hyperbolic pattern that most
people do and maybe this is something we
could talk about but I just put that on
the table because it just reveals that
the the the kind kinds of imagination of
the future and the other kinds of
decision making about the future they're
not necessarily you know in a one-to-one
mapping it's not like if you lose one
you know the whole thing falls apart
well part of what I won't ask next was
it sounds like you mentioned the
hippocampus and its memory functions but
it sounds like there's different parts
of the brain they're getting into the
game right with like putting on the play
or or anything like that have we do have
we located which specific parts of the
brain are involved in both episodic
memory and or in foresight
one one important thing to note on this
is that it's become increasingly uh I
think
common to think about the brain instead
of inter in localizationist terms where
you've got you know you've got a
particular part that does X in
particularly that's why instead you've
got these kind of wide scale networks uh
which are many brain regions kind of
communicating and interrelating together
and it's the pattern the overall pattern
of that network activity that can
perform various functions
um so that's just to say just as a
slight caveat but uh there there have
been various uh lines of evidence to try
to isolate other parts of the brain and
what they're actually doing when it
comes to putting on this this mental
play so for example we already mentioned
a little bit about
um metacognition and uh reflection and
and executive control people might be
aware that that that kind of higher
order cognition is often associated with
the prefrontal cortex
um you know because it's a it's a
reliant on executive functions uh for
instance reflecting on other parts of
cognition or keeping you know balancing
the demands of multiple competing tasks
obviously that's something you need to
do if you're going to imagine the future
you need to somehow balance that
daydreaming with the goings-on around
you in the world you know there is a
tension there as well which the brain
has to navigate it has to you know when
do I think about what's going to happen
next and when do I focus on the here and
now and you have to have some kind of
mechanism that that performs that
switching I did do a podcast a while
back with uh Robin Carhart Harris about
psychedelics and their effect on the
brain and one of the things I learned
there and elsewhere is that in terms of
Vision at least there's a whole bunch of
things that are always going on in the
brain and our brain naturally sort of
tamps them down like the vacuum state of
the brain is actually abuzz with
activity and what the psychedelics do is
not
increase activity in those
visualizations but decrease the
effectiveness of the damping mechanism
so I'm wondering if is there something
like that for Imagining the future or
like are we like secretly constantly
imagining a whole bunch of things that
our conscious brain just doesn't have
access to
well if you try and meditate for even
just a few minutes you'll discover
pretty quickly that uh you know the
brain does tend to drift into thoughts
about past and future and uh this has
been there's been studies done on on
experience sampling where you tell you
know you just probe people throughout
the day you say what are you thinking
about and you have them give you an
answer and uh unsurprisingly vast
majority well not I don't know the
specific number off the top of my head
but a lot of the time people are
thinking about the future you know is my
gym membership going to expire soon what
am I going to have for dinner tomorrow
uh you know how long until XYZ you know
they're worrying about things they're
thinking about what might happen and
this has led to uh many people arguing
that the you know it's almost a it's
it's part of what comprises the brain's
default mode uh and and as you just
mentioned Robin Harris he's done some
fascinating work on the effect of
psychedelics on the brain's kind of
default functions and just to clarify
for people who might not be aware if you
put people in a brain scanner and you
don't tell them to do anything the
question is well what what does the
brain default to what are people doing
when they have no task and it is exactly
what I just mentioned it's remembering
the past it's Imagining the future it's
thinking about the minds of other people
it's daydreaming you know it's exactly
what you would uh you would discover if
you tried to meditate and you just see
just observe for yourself what your
brain is is doing uh one of its own
accord and so I think to answer your
question yes people uh very very
commonly think about the future and of
course as I mentioned earlier balancing
the demands of the present with the you
know benefits of planning is is tricky
and obviously if you spend way too much
time in imaginary worlds you'll get
nothing done in the present and so there
is there is a kind of balancing act that
has to happen in order to make foresight
powerful good okay I mean plenty to
still say about foresighters one thing
about memory that I didn't want to quite
let go which is the idea that if it's
true true that rather than storing a
video recording of what happens we
restore some we store some much tinier
script than we can replay does that help
us understand why faulty memories can be
equally Vivid to real memories you know
all we have to do is change a little bit
of a script and then we're running it as
just as vividly in high definition as if
we'd actually been there
yeah I think that's probably fair to say
uh that the specific reasons that
memories can go awry they are varied I
mean there's many many reasons why and
there's many ways that it can go wrong
as well
um you know so you could you could
misattribute something that you've that
you've heard to someone else so let's
say uh I incorrectly on this podcast I
say oh you know I've heard such and such
a piece of evidence from such and such a
person and I've got it wrong well I'm
misattributing the source that's an
example of a memory error and that
reveals that it's not necessarily just
that the Reconstruction can go awry
which it can as you just mentioned but
it's also the these other aspects of
memory these complicated tagging
mechanisms and so on yeah and often the
kind of metacognitive ability to say
okay where did I hear that you know
identifying the source that kind of
comes along for the ride but it can also
be it can be disrupted it can you can
get it wrong
for completely other reasons just
earlier today I was reading about the
fact that there were two Beatles songs
that John and Paul completely disagreed
about who wrote them John claimed he
wrote he wrote most of the lyrics for
Eleanor Rigby and Paul said no he wrote
almost nothing and Paul said he wrote a
lot of the tune for in my life and John
said I don't know he didn't and every
other song they agreed on but still I I
mean I know I should have better than
this but I couldn't help but thinking
like how can you not know that these are
famous songs yeah yeah how can you not
know yeah it's uh it's really funny Once
you stop thinking about memory systems
as a kind of computational system for
achieving particular kinds of goals uh
the errors they do crop up everywhere
and maybe you get a little bit more
forgiving of them because you start to
say okay this is uh this is a kind of uh
this is a system that is like a like a
robot or a computer or something trying
to achieve some particular outcome and
it's it's going wrong in a a kind of
well described way and you can sort of
see where the area words are occurring
and try to correct for them
well in one of the arguments that I get
from your book and again you'll correct
me if I'm misinterpreting it but the
fundamental purpose of the brain in some
very simplistic sense is is to predict
the future is to help us anticipate
what's going to happen next the brain is
a prediction machine and maybe it's okay
for memory to be a little bit faulty if
the overall goal is to predict the
future not to reminisce about the past
that's exactly it and if you think about
even even this the sort of simple types
of memory that take place in the course
of learning so for example you know in
classical conditioning or in operant
conditioning where an animal learns to
associate particular Behavior with a
particular kind of outcome that is
memory in the sense that the animal is
kind of building up a repertoire of of
behaviors and outcomes it can cat it can
sort of store those represented their
relationships but it's really about the
future because uh you know even even
Pavlov's dog you know when he salivates
it's it's in anticipation of the coming
food it's uh it's only a memory in in a
kind of in in a certain sense really
what it's about is preparing the animal
to face an upcoming opportunity in this
case but also it's it's all about
preparing for threats as well and so you
have this you know these finely tuned
systems in the brain uh that that many
animals have and that humans have taken
to a really just an outrageously uh um
developed degree that enable preparation
for the future from from very very fine
time scales like the piece of food
that's about to you know reach my mouth
all the way to you know planning to for
the afterlife or the you know the end of
the universe as We Know It uh and so you
know it's a it's an interesting system
in the sense that it does seem to cut
across all those different time scales
so I'm curious about how it all
developed over the course of evolution
here
um yeah is this so here's a simple
question which came first memory or
foresight in evolutionary history
that's an interesting one I think I'd
probably say that they can they come on
board together at least uh you know in
some in some sense like if you
if you imagine some of the the kinds of
memory that that I just laid out like
classical conditioning uh it's a very
basic kind of learning uh it also has a
preparatory function
and so these two things they do sort of
come hand in hand even even really
simple organisms like we lay out in the
book an example from E coli you know
this is incredibly simple but it seems
to switch on digestive genes for the
digestion of maltose hours before it
reaches the maltose-rich tracts in the
digestive system of the host animal that
it's infecting
and what it's probably doing there is uh
it's it that you know it there's no need
to think that okay the E coli is
envisaging the how good is that maltose
going to be when I get there and if you
know it's not doing that instead what's
happened is over evolutionary time the
variance that that did that were more
likely to survive and and pass on those
beneficial genes to the Next Generation
and so over time you can get very
functioning forms of preparation
evolving without any anyone really
having to develop a considered plan
about how it all is going to work
um yeah does the E coli have a memory
correspondingly
well I mean the E coli has it's got a
memory in in the sense that it's storing
it you know that it's evolved to
represent the relation between I mean
it's not representing anything
consciously or in any kind of mind but
it's there is a genetically hardwired
relation that is you know Remembered in
scare quotes between the time course of
events that it needs to correspondingly
prepare for you know for the people at
home can't see the the scare quotes I'm
putting around all of the everything in
that sentence uh because obviously you
know the E coli is not thinking about
anything
well but it it yeah so you're saying
that the E coli is sort of an even more
primitive version of the squirrel just
doing something automatically right it's
not envisioning the future ahead of time
but if it's true that over the course of
evolutionary history there are all sorts
of these capacities that develop in
animals or even pre-animals to do
something to prepare effectively right
for the future
um did our imaginative capacities latch
on to them and take advantage of them
once they did spring up in this more
human uh visualizable way
yeah I think it's an extremely gradual
process
um the the ability to imagine the future
as humans do it was actually something
that gave Darwin pause because he he
said at one point in his autobiography
that he was most inclined to believe in
God when contemplating how such a
capacity to Traverse time in your own
mind could have possibly evolved through
blind chance or necessity
and so when you just look on the face of
it at the final product which is this
you know quite remarkable ability to you
know span the the ages in your mind's
eye that seems very difficult to try and
understand in terms of how it could have
how it could have evolved but I think as
you just said the right way to think
about it is to kind of chart the
trajectory and think about all the small
incremental steps that would have led to
that ability uh and in the book we we
kind of take as our starting point the
split that led to Modern chimpanzees and
modern humans but of course you can go
much much earlier I know you had um
Malcolm McIver on the on the podcast and
he's done some you know only relatively
recently found you know found his work
but arguing that the transition from
from water to land was was pivotal was a
pivotal moment so maybe that's a maybe
that's a one of the steps that you can
zoom in on and you can say okay what
were the processes that that led to you
know an increasing imagination of the
future in those particular species and
then kind of go from there
so you're saying on the one hand that
this imaginative capacity that we have
grew up gradually over by evolutionary
time but you also do want to say just so
or at least tell me if this is right or
not or say it as clearly as possible we
can do it way better than anyone else
can in the uh in the set of animals and
vegetables here on Earth
correct
so is there is both things can be true
it can have you can have a you can have
a gradual increase in some competency
that
if it ends up developing a particular
capacity you know way better than than
other animals can do it as you know
we're particularly good at bipedal
locomotion as well yeah you know just
you know and some people are very
interested in that uh and so you know
it's it's really it shouldn't be
particularly controversial just you just
look at uh at the human ability to to
travel mentally in time and it is just
obviously way way better at least it's
more articulated you can look further
into the future you can anticipate
possibilities contingencies you can go
into remote distant times you can
anticipate drives that you don't
currently possess
all of those things uh you know they are
much more articulated than other other
animals but that is not to say that
other animals cannot they have no
ability to to engage with the future
they have no future directed capacities
and understand you know and that is and
it's a gradually acquired trait uh one
one key you know one one aside here is
important for people to bear in mind is
that
if all the other hominins that humans
once shared the planet with were still
alive then the gradual you know uh
acquire a gradually acquired trait would
look more gradually acquired sure but
all of the intermediates have gone
extinct and so now there looks to be
sort of as Thomas my collaborator has
argued in his previous book The Gap
there does now appear to be a Chasm
between the mental abilities of humans
and all of the rest of the animals that
are currently alive but part of that is
an artifact it's an illusion based on
the fact that all of the intermediary
species have gone extinct okay perfectly
fair and so what is it that in the book
you talk about the differences between
chimps and humans I mean how specific
can we be is it is it something that a
physicist would call a phase transition
you know along the way where there's a
relatively uh quick sort of snowballing
effect that changed things relatively
rapidly
I think that's probably fair but at the
same time
um once you dive into the process by
which this ability evolved uh you can
see you can start to see you know
precisely how it might have come about I
mean this is not completely well
understood by any stretch obviously the
archeology of all this is is uh very
murky it's it's very far in the past
um but uh you know just in the same way
that you can have gradual changes for
instance as the temperature changes are
you know once in water and then it
becomes Ice uh you know it's a similar
kind of thing can happen here where all
of the different component Pieces come
about and then when they're combined in
this particular array that we have it
enables some of this extremely complex
and Powerful behavior and cognition
how close can chimps come what is what
how good is their capacity to imagine
the future
okay yeah so maybe we could just
describe some of the behaviors that are
particularly interesting so for example
um chimpanzees will they you know many
people know by now they use tools uh but
they will will sometimes even pick up a
tool for example a rock that they're
going to use to crush a nut uh you know
a few hundred yards away from where they
end up using it okay so they have a
drive they're acting on that drive they
they're using a tool to solve some
problem and um during my PhD I worked a
little bit with uh that with chimpanzees
and you know if you drop a grape outside
their enclosure they will leave the
enclosure they'll go into the other part
of the area they'll get a stick they'll
they'll peel off the the leaves from the
stick and they'll use that sticker to
kind of fish the grape from underneath
the so clearly they can represent a
problem in their Mind's Eye sufficiently
to seek an immediate solution to that
problem uh that's future directed they
also
um will they they have various other
kinds of future directed behaviors in
the sense that they'll they'll navigate
uh and they seem to do group planning
you know they they they there's even
reports of them hunting for example
um and and doing border patrols and this
kind of stuff what what one of the
things they don't seem to be able to do
or at least a kind of a hypothesis and I
will say a contentious hypothesis is
that one of the things they can't do is
actually anticipate a drive state that
they do not currently possess ah so that
could be a you know this is drilling
down a little bit into the details now
but uh the Bischoff curler hypothesis as
it's so called
um and uh Thomas was one of the people
that put this forward is that they
cannot represent they cannot act upon a
drive State they do not currently
possess to make that more concrete let's
say the Chimpanzee is not currently
thirsty
it will not
go and gather water in anticipation of
being thirsty tomorrow
I see and this has to do with the
recursion and metacognition we talked
about before we have to be able to run a
little virtual machine inside our head
that imagines ourselves being thirsty in
the future
yeah and that's kind of difficult
because it you you have to well it's
very difficult you have to disengage
from the current drives that you have to
represent your own preferences in the
future so it requires both a kind of uh
prospective thinking you know imagining
a situation removed in time but it also
involves representing your own
preference function changing in that
future
how good are and so that's just an
example of one of the things that that
that has not been comprehensively
falsified
um and so there's there's no good
evidence that they can achieve that how
good are chimps at understanding the
state of mind and knowledge of other
Minds other chimps other human beings
yeah it's good you raise that because
it's it's obviously uh very related uh
in some sense when you are imagining
your own preferences changing in the
future you're using a very similar kind
of cognitive capacity as you would use
to represent the mind of another person
uh so you know if I'm trying to
anticipate what you're going to ask me
next what I'm doing is is doing some
kind of mind reading on you but I might
also just apply that same kind of mind
reading to myself
chimpanzees lack the theory of Mind
capacities that we have at least they
are nowhere near as articulated there is
some tantalizing evidence that they
track the false beliefs that other
agents other other chimpanzees or other
humans have and some really interesting
work by um Chris krupenier and his
colleagues they've done eye tracking
experiments with chimpanzees to
basically run a version of the of a
false belief task where the chimpanzees
eyes are tracked to see if they look at
where they fall at where they think a
person falsely believes an object is
hidden even when the chimpanzee
themselves know that it's hidden
somewhere else
and so if they and and they do do that
they do they look they look longer at a
position at a place where they they uh
have reason to suspect that a another
individual believes something is hidden
so that's a you know but that's a pretty
low bar in some sense I mean it's an
impressive ability yeah but it but it's
not the kind of it's nothing near like
what we can do where I can I can
appreciate that you know that I know
something and that meanwhile you know my
my friend Josh doesn't know that either
of us know that thing you know and it
gets a little tricky once you get you
know too embedded right but the
fundamental ability is is very
sophisticated
yeah and so your argument is basically
that there is a Continuum it's gradual
it wasn't magic or anything like that
but still there's a big difference in
this particular capacity between a
modern day human and our closest
competition here on Earth
exactly and I think and and that and
that has various consequences for trying
to understand what it means to be human
and also trying to understand how to use
that ability
wisely because it's it's something that
other animals don't possess and that and
as you say it's not magic it evolved
gradually we don't know exactly how uh
but it's it's like any other problem in
science where if you accumulate more and
more data and you run and you try and
falsify the hypotheses as they come up
you could you could imagine a full a
full picture uh at least in principle of
how this ability to travel mentally in
time evolved uh through natural
selection
yeah and and I think it does sound to me
smell to me whatever like a phase
transition in the sense that once you do
develop that capacity enough it just
opens up a whole bunch of other things
uh that are important so I'll ask you
some and feel free to to mention others
that are in there the ability to make
contingency plans right the ability to
not only make a plan but to have a
backup plan if it goes wrong that that
sounds like a pretty human ability
that is probably one of the key defining
things that makes it unique uh as I
mentioned earlier that um with the tube
task when young children are given that
upside down y-shaped tube uh they before
around age four they only cover one or
the other exit well when you give that
exact same task to chimpanzees and other
gray tapes they also tend to only ever
really cover one or the other exit and
they'll move their hand back and forth
between the two exits they'll even
sometimes switch hands
and they don't seem to represent the
fact that they could be wrong about
their prediction and therefore that they
need to cover both exits in order to
guarantee that they're going to get the
grape falling out of the tube uh they do
occasionally use both hands uh but then
they go back on the very next trial to
only using one hand so the penny hasn't
really dropped there they don't they
don't seem to actually understand that
in order to guarantee the prize 100 of
the time which can be done if you set
the right contingency plan by putting
two hands out uh you you can't guarantee
that you're going to get the prize
that's a rudimentary form of contingency
planning in humans we use that same
basic capacity for contingency planning
in a huge variety of different important
ways for instance you might you know we
all have plan a for you know career or
relationship or anything else in life
and but you recognize that things don't
go according to plan you know you might
you just things do not the reality has a
way of getting in the way of your best
laid plans you know
and songs all about this yeah you know
the possibilities being being
obliterated as as uh as reality gets in
the way so contingency planning can be
extremely useful there because for
example you might you know this
underpins the entire insurance industry
yeah because uh this and the fundamental
cognitive Insight that the future might
not turn out is anticipated drives us to
do something about it
um and uh yeah so that's just an example
of where as you maybe you're right
exactly it could be a phase transition
in the sense that if you don't have all
the component capacities working
together to generate that kind of
foresight well none of the other
implications follow
and the downside of this is that we can
have regret right we can imagine oh I
could have done something differently
and that would have been better this
seems like is that is it a uniquely
human capacity also
probably yeah probably I think it's it's
hard to tell it's one of those it's
another one of those difficult ones
where you obviously can't read their
mind you need careful Behavioral Studies
uh that the studies are difficult to do
in this case because you're trying to
tease apart uh the reaction to just not
getting what you want
from the reaction driven by a
contemplation of a counter factual of
what I could have got instead sure so
those those two things are very closely
related but they're not the same so it's
you know it's one thing to be frustrated
when things don't go according to plan
because you you know you had a goal and
it was not realized and other animals
will readily get frustrated when their
goals are not realized but what we do is
languish over uh long ago committed sins
or uh you know embarrassing things we
said a long time ago we're kind of
taking this mental time machine for a
spin into an alternative reality and
thinking how much better it could have
been if I just said something slightly
better or reacted in a in a more
cooler-headed way to some problem so
that's a you know this mental time
machine is a blessing and a curse
actually I think it's it's not all
hunky-dory but but like you say these
are we have to be able to draw some
pretty fine distinctions to say these
clearly I mean we all have seen pictures
of dogs looking girl guilty after
they've done something yeah and but it's
not regret right it's a little bit more
automatic
I don't know really exactly what's
happening in in those cases I mean you
can you can imagine a situation where
you condition an animal to experience
highly negative emotion in response to
some uh some stimulus because in the
past it has been associated with that
negative outcome so for example if every
time the the dog jumps on the couch you
know gets a gets a smack or gets yelled
at or something that jumps off the couch
well now when it's on the couch it's
anticip you know it might have
anticipated the negative outcome
um but you know exactly what's going on
in those cases I I don't really know I
mean there's there's fascinating work
recently uh on dogs but it's funnily
enough they really the cognition of dogs
was was ignored for quite a while
in comparative psychology relatively
speaking but recently there's been a
kind of a big push towards trying to
understand canine cognition because they
are extremely clever animals and they
have a long co-evolutionary history with
human right
um which uh but maybe that takes us too
far afield but anyway it's it's a very
interesting kind of research area
because these are highly social pack
animals that have co-evolved with human
beings for thousands of years and and
which have been now selectively bred for
all these traits that we find desirable
and so the cognition there it's like
it's actually a very interesting test
bed for understanding some things about
you know the processes of domestication
or you know what does it mean for
something to be to be a threat to these
animals and so on uh so it's an
interesting area is that one of the
reasons why they haven't been studied
because the co-evolution sort of
complicates the whole thing like they've
been around human beings for so long
we've contaminated them
oh they're so contaminated they're
completely you know if you're studying
domestic dogs it's uh it's just a it's
it's extremely difficult
um I'm blanking on the name right now
but there's some work being done at
Harvard looking at the um that the brain
structures and the cognitive capacities
of different domestic dog breeds okay
and the the brains of these animals have
also been radically altered by the
domestication process just as their
bodies have been uh so you know they
have the domestication produces
different ears and Tails and coats and
everything but it also obviously
radically changes their behavior
unsurprisingly that is reflected in the
brain uh the the actual brain structures
uh involved in different kinds of
behaviors in different animal in
different dog breeds
are correspondingly changed on the basis
of like what they're good at or what
they're you know scared of or whatever
so it's it's an interesting one I will
spare our audience my dispositions on
cats because I I I've already I had Carl
friston on the podcast and and I nice
gave him my theory that one of my cats
has the ability to imagine the future
and the other one does not the other one
just lives absolutely in the moment and
without regret or fear but the and the
the first one is sort of always fretting
about something or another uh so good
plenty of work to be done by Future
generations of graduate students here
um yeah exactly you just need some dogs
and a and a multi-million dollar fmri
scan and you'll be they'll be set to go
this sounds like one of the more fun
things you can do within this subfield
um yeah I guess I'd be remiss if I
didn't bring up the marshmallow test
right uh because is our ability to
restrain ourselves and exhibit willpower
is that related to our ability to
imagine the future
so this is close to very close to what I
do kind of on a day-to-day basis in my
personal research work which is uh you
know what kind of the the behavioral
economics and the psychology of a
long-term decision making and so the
marshmallow tests for people that don't
know I mean many people have seen cute
videos of children trying to resist the
temptation an experimental will place a
marshmallow in front of the child and
say that if you wait until I come back
you can have a second marshmallow and
then the children are left in the room
to you know commence their struggle with
temptation if they eat the marshmallow
before the other person before the
experimenter comes back well then okay
you that's it if you come back and
there's it's still there you get another
one now uh what's pretty interesting
there is that uh when that study I mean
there's a lot to say on this the first
thing might just be that as people will
know there's a kind of whole cottage
industry in Psychology looking at what
the marshmallow test performance
predicts later and so for example it's
been found that uh as if people you know
children wait longer for the second
marshmallow well then they also have
higher SAT scores and they perform
better in various other ways in in later
life there's you know various
longitudinal studies that have been done
there
however like that their story really is
a is actually more complicated than that
than it seems a first blush so recent
attempts to replicate the marshmallow
study correlations with later life
outcomes has found that it's hugely
contaminated by things like SES
socioeconomic status okay
so for example if uh you're in yeah if
you're in the kind of environment where
delayed rewards do not actually manifest
as promised well then you're also in the
kind of environment where it makes
little sense to delay gratification
right so and so uh it's a lot of the
stuff that I've done research I've done
is looked at the kinds of environments
the kind of situations where it actually
makes more sense to prioritize the
immediate reward and that's kind of put
put the marshmallow test on a slightly
different spin on it which is to
emphasize the flexibility of knowing
when it makes sense to wait and when
it's better to just go for it
and okay but then what is the connection
to just foresight as an ability is there
any way that we can measure that uh
there's a relationship between one
marshmallow versus two marshmallow and
one's ability to vividly imagine the
future consequences
yeah great so that's that's a an ongoing
question it's whether you know to what
extent does this ability to actually
vividly imagine yourself in the future
influence the kinds of decisions where
the outcomes play out only over time
right and as I mentioned earlier one of
the more
um one of the things that really throws
that relationship into question is that
patient KC who'd lost his ability to
imagine himself in the future
nonetheless discounted the future
discounted rewards and outcomes in the
future normally
and Sophie just for your listeners yeah
you know if you want to study something
like the marshmallow test in adults they
don't respond quite as well to
marshmallows as children do and so you
know but what they do respond to is
money yeah and so some of the common
tasks that you you can do which are kind
of analogous to the marshmallow tasks
but they're not the same is you ask
people to make various decisions about
different amounts of money distributed
at different points in time so for
example would you rather have ten
dollars now or fifteen dollars in one
month and then if I ask you many
questions like that and I change both
the amounts of money and the distances
in time then I can compute for a given
person the extent to which as rewards
move further and further away in time
how do they lose their subjective value
and you can fit preference functions to
those uh preference to those curves and
you can say okay for a given person how
steeply do they discount rewards as they
move in further away in time
now that discounting curve can then be
used you can say okay well how is that
affected by the ability to think about
the future
and as I already mentioned this patient
KC who cannot imagine the future
discounts normally right but this so
This has led to some suggestions that
maybe in order to make uh more in order
to make flexible decisions about time
you need the ability to imagine the
future and so for example what we've
found in some studies and a lot of other
people have found now is as well is that
if you ask people to imagine future
events while they're making these kinds
of decisions you can shift their
discounting curve you can make them more
willing to wait for delayed payoffs
probably by making the future more Vivid
more concrete and uh more more more
immediately relatable to the present
okay so that's the relationship so you
can shift the discounting curve based on
how Vivid that imagination is
yes yes exactly and there's been some
work done by
um Hal hirschfield uh showing that if
you get if you show people for example
virtual reality age progressed versions
of their own face then they are more
willing to save for a retirement for
example
but but also you point out that people
are wildly irrational like there's the
people who would rather have a five
thousand dollar vacation than a ten
thousand dollar wad of cash
yeah and there's some interesting
situations where the discounting curve
gets a bit funky so for example you know
people might sometimes actually prefer
to as you just said they'll prefer to
take a voucher for like if you know a
nice massage instead of an equivalent
cash prize even if the cash prize is
bigger
and on the face of it that seems kind of
strange because well couldn't you just
buy the massage with the money and then
you know you've got the on the way home
have a nice cup of coffee with this with
the uh with the change
and what it turns out people are doing
in those kinds of situations is actually
anticipating that if they take the cash
they'll use it for boring Essentials so
if I if they take the cash they know
their own preference function they know
what they're like they know that what
they'll probably do is get home and
they'll end up putting it just into
their into the along alongside the rest
of their money they'll end up buying a
toothbrush with it or something and so
instead of that what what people do is
they kind of pre-commit to Indulgence
which is to say that they intentionally
choose a lower value reward that they
know is going to be used for a
pleasurable experience this seems like a
very very deep fact about human
psychology which is that we can only
imagine the future but we have a
somewhat adversarial relationship to our
future selves
it's a funny way to put it yeah yeah
exactly it's it's not a we're not on
necessarily on great terms with our
future self uh all the time or with our
past self for that matter uh you know
it's it's a very funny situation it's
almost a there's a kind of game same
theoretical tension if you if you start
to if you think about the the mind as
being made up of many selves distributed
across time the relationship between all
of those selves can actually be modeled
in a kind of game theoretical sense as
if they were all individual agents and
that leads to some very interesting work
on for example what leads people to
pre-commit to decisions where they
intentionally tie their own hands in
advance of some upcoming challenge
because they know that their future self
can't be relied on right you know take
take care of these classic examples of
like you know hiding the donuts at the
back of the fridge or flashing your your
cigarettes down the toilet I mean one
thing I do is like most days if I really
need to get some writing done I now have
a website Blocker on my laptop
you know yeah it's just turn that thing
on and say okay you are not going on
Twitter now for eight hours you know if
this is the work day now right and yeah
and so it understanding that that
behavior is is quite difficult it's
almost paradoxical in a sense because
people are in that sense intentionally
restricting their own freedoms to win a
battle against a future version of
themselves
they're self-aware enough to know that
we're weak I mean it makes me wonder
whether or not dogs or chimpanzees can
have imposter syndrome can they like
feel that they're not up to a task or
just be embarrassed like there's this
ability to imagine all these different
hypotheticals really weighing us down
with anxiety as as human beings in a way
that other animals don't suffer
I think so I think uh one of the things
one of the interesting things that um
andal tolving who was responsible for
making that semantic episodic
distinction that we talked about earlier
one of the things he said about KC the
patient who who lost access to the
future is that he's in many ways he's
happier than the rest of us because he
doesn't worry about the future and uh he
doesn't know he doesn't worry about the
fact that he's gonna die right uh
because he he has no mental access to
that to the fourth dimension so he's uh
he's you know he's not plagued by that
and I think on a moment's reflection
people will will recognize that their
mental time machine will often dredge up
really negative possibilities you know
on the face of it you could imagine a
functional evolutionary explanation for
that
which is that it's very useful to
anticipate threats in your environment
but it's a double-edged sword it's
simultaneously extremely functional in
the sense that it lets you prepare for
upcoming dangers but it also plagues you
with
all the worries about all the possible
things that could go wrong and that's
especially problematic because of the
the mutually exclusive nature of our
mental time issue the fact that I could
say oh this could go wrong or or maybe
this could go wrong you know you just go
through the list it's like here's a
thousand different ways that this thing
could go wrong and you have mental
access to all of them lucky
well I do want to no you know now that
we've gotten that on the table we can
speak up for some of the positive
aspects right I mean there's a
relationship there's a million
relationships maybe pick out your
favorites between
um
uh the ability to imagine the future and
developing tools social cooperation
language right like all these things we
associate specifically with humanity and
its social structures in some way
they're super reliant on this ability
yeah fundamentally Reliant and actually
this this is nice because it brings us
to kind of come full circle on the The
evolutionary question which we stopped
we opened that door we didn't really
finish the the kind of point there which
was you know how did this thing evolve
this this ability to to imagine the
future evolve in in our hominin
ancestors
um and uh in the book we kind of we like
I said we start at the split leading to
Modern chimpanzees and we kind of go
through how this happened maybe I'll
just take a a waypoint which directly
addresses your question about some of
the key Technologies as uh to illustrate
so something like a bag I mean I know it
sounds funny on the face on the face of
it but a mobile carrying container is
actually one of the most important
fundamental innovations that human
beings have ever devised you know forget
your you know your fire and your and
your and your axes and stuff the mobile
container it's actually extremely
important and often overlooked in
archeology but it's uh it's foundational
because it it represents this ability to
to anticipate that what I currently have
I could bring with me into the future
and not only that but I can now store
multiple objects that I might need given
what the future could hold
and once you have a mobile container
that actually produces new uh new
incentives new selective pressures on
Preparation because only now does it
make sense to prepare multiple Tools in
advance
four mobile containers you you basically
if you make a tool you can carry it with
you but you can that's it you only have
the carrying capacity of your of your
hands and that's not enough if you want
to actually become a you know a species
that has now found its way to every you
know every ecosystem on the planet
including some extremely hostile ones
you need a kind of mobile life support
system you need various tools you need
clothes you need all these different
bits and pieces and that's unlocked by
the ability to carry them with you and
so this actually illustrates something
kind of fundamental which is there's
actually a feedback loop between the
technology that we create using our
foresight
and the evolution of foresight itself
because if I use my foresight to create
a bag in collaboration with many other
people well now that bag itself feeds
back to create new pressure on the next
generation of people who are now growing
up in an ecosystem where bags exist you
know in a society where that can be
taken advantage of it's a new feature of
the environment it's a constructed niche
and so now that is going to feedback to
actually increase the the farsightedness
that brought the thing into existence in
the first place
and now you can imagine how that might
ratchet up do we know when the first bag
was ever used
we don't know when the first bag was
ever used and the the reason is that uh
they're made of of materials that don't
tend to uh last the ages there's
evidence from around 100 000 years ago
that you know hard evidence that people
are using shells to store things like
pigments for for uh you know creating
markings
um and then you know even more recent
that 50 000 years ago there's evidence
of you know there was a great excitement
in the scientific Community when even a
scraggly little piece of cord was found
from a neanderthal site because it's
like well that's you know that's amazing
it's just literally like a tiny little
piece of cord but it implies that they
were they were creating uh possibly
slings or straps or some kind of a
carrying device I mean who knows what
they were actually using it for and
there's this kind of tool use
uh come before language as far as We
Know
well
the evolution of languages
tricky to pin that very tricky to pin
down
um to Tool use in language probably
co-evolve in some very fundamental ways
so for example uh in in a similar way as
I just laid out with the the other
feedback loop with bags as you become
increasingly reliant on tools it also
becomes important to be able to pass
those tools to other people and to teach
them how to use them
and uh so we've already addressed that
you know one of the technological
aspects you know mobile containers as an
example of of a piece of technology that
foresight enables but as you mentioned
as well there's also social institutions
and teaching is one of them so in order
to teach you represent the mind of
another person and you anticipate what
they need to know in the future and then
you attempt to shape their mind towards
the goal of that expertise
and so teaching is actually really
fundamentally reliant on foresight as
well because it involves people who are
in the know you know transmitting
lessons to people who are not in the
know in order to to pass those on
it just seems like there's a very
natural opportunity at least for
co-evolution between language and
foresight uh for one thing we can tell
stories right I mean storytelling I
don't know what people think about the
origin of language did we tell
counterfactual stories as soon as we
started constructing complex sentences I
probably not but I honestly don't know
yeah the argument has been made that
ultimately language evolved at least in
pot and maybe primarily to share our
mental time travels okay and uh yeah so
exactly as you sort of insinuated there
like there's this there is a a very deep
relationship between these these
capacities uh and uh it might even be
the case although it's hard to prove
that
um that that the reason we even have
language in the first place is because
it enables us to come to transmit these
lessons about things that are not here
and now and linguists will point to
displacement what they call displacement
as a key feature of what makes human
language different from the
communication systems of other animals
displacement just refers to the fact
that our language systems can represent
or refer to things that are not in our
immediate perceptual environment
I can I can use my language to refer to
things that are distant in time and
space
and what's the relationship of that
between that and the ability to use
language to refer to hypotheticals you
know to say or to make a contract say if
you do this then I will do that that
seems like something we couldn't have
done without language and the ability to
have some foresight
yeah that's a great example
um you know so in in the book we talk
about various things like even even uh
you know exchange systems and bartering
contracts are a big part of that reliant
on foresight again because you
representing the fact that in the future
you know you owe me something and I
expect to get it back
and that might not be for a long period
of time yeah between now and and then
and so you know accounting systems
there's a good good uh reason to believe
that those essentially first arose
because they enable you to offsource the
difficulty of keeping track who of who
owes what to whom you know and when the
bill is due uh across time and so you
know writing itself
provides a tool an offloading to
cognitive offloading tool for
externalizing representations of future
events that need to be kept track of you
know bearing in mind that as I said this
kind of contingency planning thing you
you represent so many mutually exclusive
possibilities that there's too many to
carry in the same way that you you need
it you need a bag to carry all of your
tools you might need you need external
artifacts that can where you can encode
and and represent all of the possible
Futures that you need to keep track of I
mean it does seem like uh a bunch of
things happened at once and I don't know
if there was a single event but they but
they do co-evolve I'm going to start
using the word of in all my sentences
from now on because it's yeah so very
helpful but yeah but you know foresight
uh tool use social cooperation contracts
uh language storytelling and we're still
we still haven't
equilibrated right like we're still
feeling out what that means and what we
can do with all these capacities and I'm
not even going to mention like Twitter
drama but it's an example of uh all the
ways that we're still learning how to
communicate and what it means for us
yeah exactly I mean learning how to
communicate and what it means to us and
I think also on in some way learning how
to use our our abilities to think about
the future and plan for it I mean it's
this will come as no surprise to anyone
that like our ability for mental time
travel is not Clairvoyance yeah you know
it's it's definitely not perfect by any
stretch and uh many of the errors of of
planning and anticipation are some of
the most catastrophic that we make
because uh you know many reasons we can
go into some of the details about you
know where where the psychology how the
psychology can let us down uh in the in
the you know the modern era but many
situations where you invest in some
vision of the future and you believe
that this is going to work and it
doesn't work and you fail
and so trying to get to grips with how
how to use foresight especially and in
terms of its relationship to our
Technologies uh is I think one of the
key it's one of the key challenges that
we're facing now I mean because you you
know if you're gonna if we're gonna
navigate into a better future or one one
way to do that is to understand that you
know the mental machine that actually
enables you to think about the future at
all in the first place
well that's perfect because it leads in
it's sort of the flip side of what I was
going to do for the very last question
to wind things up
you just mentioned how uh there's sort
of systematic ways in which our
predictive abilities fall short
sometimes but on the flip side sometimes
we make pretty good predictions but we
don't take them seriously enough right
when if they're too long term or too
outside our scope we're seeing this with
various issues like climate change and
other big picture risks to the Earth uh
is there some sense in which we can be
better at actually believing our own
abilities in this sense is that
something that uh we can hope for for
the future as we imagine possible
Futures
yeah I think we need to be optimistic
about our abilities to think about the
future I mean a slightly Whimsical way
of thinking about it but it is true is
that because we are the only animals
with this access to the to the fourth
dimension that we do have that also
burdens us and us alone with the
responsibility to Steward that future
and to get it right and you know no one
else is going to do it and so on the one
hand it's responsibility but on the
other hand that's it's a nice way of
saying that actually we are the most
far-sighted creature that has ever
existed and we have an incredibly
sophisticated and Powerful mental time
machine in our skulls that we could use
to to Really create a better future so
that's one optimistic way of thinking
about it but just to flip the question
on his head a little bit uh I think if
anything we need to believe Less in our
abilities for mental time travel and
what I mean by that is just that we need
to adopt that that sort of skepticism
that we talked about earlier the kind of
metacognitive appraisal of our
inabilities we say okay how could this
go wrong
you know much in the same way as the the
young children with the fork tube task
you know it does it will not work to
just put one hand out you know
underneath the tubes we we need to and
we need to realize that we could be
wrong and so I think many of the
problems that that we really face are
actually people being too gung-ho in
there in their predictions uh and
getting too invested in in what they
believe the future will be like but when
you realize that the future is actually
just a like like we talked about already
a mental theater you know a Conjuring
trick in a way where we've we've created
this mental representation it's actually
very similar to just making something up
completely fictitiously and so realizing
that puts a kind of a fine point on the
skepticism that we should apply to our
own predictions and obviously science is
all about doing that it's it's looking
at your predictions and attempting
explicitly to falsify them
these very good things to think about uh
about the future I'm not sure whether
it's an optimistic or pessimistic
inclusion right there but anyway I think
we should take seriously our ability to
make contingency plans if that's one of
the things that Evolution has given to
us so Adam bully thanks so much for
being on the mindscape podcast that was
great talking to you thank you very much
for having me appreciate it
[Music]
la la la la
[Music]